this brings teaser this video is once
again not one that I made up I actually
don't remember the first time that I
heard it I think it was in the back of a
magazine I want to say Scientific
American and and me and a bunch of
buddies we were traveling through Europe
and it kind of became our pastime to do
these brain teasers in the back of
magazines and just so you know I think a
lot of people think that you know these
type of brain teasers you can just read
them and solve them and if you can't
solve them then you're not good at this
type of thing this brain teaser I'm
about to give you I just kind of sat and
thought about it and I mean my buddies
we argued about it for literally about a
day and then I just slept on it and then
the first thing in the morning I like
woke up all my friend that's like I
figured it out so this isn't some kind
of easy thing and and I encourage you
know just listen to the statement
understand it and then you know pause
the video and then think about it for 24
hours and then come back to it and one
you'll probably solve it yourself and if
you don't in 24 or 48 hours and you'll
probably find the solution that much
more satisfying so this is the problem
of the toddlers toddlers not toddlers
toddlers I have a well I have an infant
so words like toddler are in my brain
but this is the problem of the toddler
so there are five guys in front of you
and that's one of them two three or five
they don't have to be guys they could be
of any gender and four of them are what
we called toddlers and what a toddler so
four of them for toddlers for toddlers
and what a toddler does is they the
first time you ask them a question
they're either going to tell the truth
and they're going to lie
so truth or a lie but then the second
time that you ask them they're going to
toggle they're going to switch so the
second time you ask them a question if
they told the truth the first time then
the next time you ask that same person a
question they're going to switch to
lying but if they lied the first time
you ask them a question
then they're gonna switch to telling the
truth and then it goes on and so on and
so forth so if you ask the same person
the third question if they told the
truth the first time then they'll lie
the second time you ask them a question
and then the third time they'll tell
them the truth
it's like if I was a toddler and you
said hey you what is your name and if I
said oh my name is Bill then clearly I'm
lying that first time and then you say
you point it to me again and you say
what is your name them say oh my name is
Sal and then if you were asking me again
what is your name I would say oh my name
is Susan and if you ask me again my name
is Sal so this is so the first time I
just decided to lie but I just as easy
just as easily I could have decided to
tell the truth the first time you might
have you know said hey you what's your
name I still hadn't said Sal and then
you asked me what's your name again and
I would have said Elizabeth and then you
asked me what's my name again I would
say oh with my name is Sal and then
again what's your name and I would say
you know George Washington or something
arbitrary but I think you get the idea
a toddler the first you know I don't
know who's the target let's say that
this is a toddler the first time you ask
some question they might lie they might
tell the truth but if they lie the next
time you ask the same person a question
they're gonna tell the truth
but if the first time you ask them a
question and they did tell the truth the
next time you ask the same personal
question he or she is going to lie so
that's a toddler so you can already
imagine this is I mean I don't know the
first time that I read the problem it
kind of made my brain hurt this notion
of a toddler it's much easier when
there's a reality where people only lie
or only tell the truth it's much harder
when they toggle and not only they
toggle but their initial state whether
they start telling the truth or they
start off lying you don't know that's
arbitrary there's no way of predicting
whether this person first of all we
don't know if this person is a toddler
because I said there's only four
toddlers but even if they are a toddler
I don't even know if the first time I
asked them a question whether they're
going to tell the truth or whether
they're going to lie so for our more
toddlers what's the fifth well you
probably could guess because this is how
these brain teasers go the fifth is the
truth teller and he's much simpler or he
or she I don't want to give any clues on
who it might be is a truth teller and a
truth teller always tells the truth
always tells the truth
so this brain teaser
or the goal of this brain teaser is to
figure out who is the truth teller so
you want to know which of these five
people is the solicited goal whose truth
teller and as you can imagine you don't
have infinite questions to do this with
you have exactly two questions to do
this with and you have two questions and
those two questions they can be you know
one question to this guy and then
another question to this guy both
questions could be to this guy both
questions could be to her right over
there so the questions don't have to be
the same person although they can be the
same person or they could be kind of to
two different people so you have two
questions any question to ask of any cop
you know any combination of either two
questions to one person or two questions
to two people to figure and by the end
of those two questions you should know
for sure who is the truth teller and
that is the the brainteaser statement so
pause it now if you don't want any hints
or the solution or anything else so you
know I encourage you to pause it and
think about it for at least for at least
a day and you know sleep on it because a
lot of you know although the real math
problems or logic problems that are
worth solving aren't the ones that you
can solve right when you see them
they're the ones that you kind of sit
and let your brain do a little
background processing while you sleep so
with that said hopefully you've stopped
it and now you've resumed it after after
really struggling with this for a long
period not eating and sleeping and and
all the things that normal people do and
now you're ready for the solution or
even better you're ready to confirm your
solution so first I'll give you a hint I
mean you know it's a tough question I
struggled with this at first I was just
like you know how do you know when you
ask someone a question how do you know
if they're lying or not
how do you know if they're the truth
teller how do you know if they're a
toddler you don't have any information
so the crux of this problem is to it's
essentially it doesn't matter who you're
asking the question to the first time
around and actually the solution is it
doesn't matter who you're asking to the
question the second time around you want
to ask a question
so that no matter what they say you know
what they're going to do the second time
around you know whether they're going to
tell the truth the second time around or
you know whether they're going to lie
the second time around and that's a hint
and if you just want a hint if they keep
thinking about it pause it again because
I'm about to give you a solution so
question one so question one and you can
pick any of the five people to ask this
question to and that's kind of the
nature of one of these solutions there's
no reason for you to pick one of the
five over the other they're all equally
likely to be the truth teller so you ask
them are you the truth teller are you
the truth teller truth teller
so let's think about a couple of of
citizens well first of all they're
either gonna answer to this yes or no
right
so the either gonna say there's going to
be two situations they either gonna say
yes or they're going to say no so if
someone says yes - are they the truth
teller it means that they are either
that they they they are the truth teller
telling the truth truth teller telling
truth telling truth or they are a lying
toddler a lying toddler if they say that
they are not the truth teller they
clearly cannot be the truth teller
because the truth teller cannot lie
about not being the truth teller and so
they have to be a toddler and they be an
honest toddler being a toddler who's
telling the truth right so it would be a
truthful toddler truthful truthful
toddler right remember I asked anybody
any of these five people right here said
are you the truth teller if they say yes
I immediately know that they're either
the truth teller telling the truth or
they're a lying toddler if they say no I
know that they are a truthful toddler
now what's interesting is in this
scenario if they say yes what do I know
that they're going to do next so if this
is a if this is the truth telling if
this is a the truth teller and they told
the truth that this on the second
question they're going to
tell the truth again they're gonna tell
the truth on on question number two if
they're the lying toddler what are they
gonna do when you ask him another
question
well they toggle if they lie the first
time you ask them they're gonna tell the
truth the second time you ask them so
they're going to tell the truth on
question number two right so if the
person says yes - are you the truth
teller you immediately know no matter
who they are that they're gonna tell the
truth on question number two so if you
can know for a fact that the person
gonna tell the truth on question number
two you - you ask them who is the truth
teller who so this is number two who is
the truth teller so it's kind of weird
you go to someone and say are you the
truth teller and and they'll say yes and
then you ask them again who is the truth
teller and then because they have to
tell the truth they will actually
they'll either say if it was this case
they say I am the truth teller or if
it's this case they'll say no that dude
over there is the truth teller and then
you'll know who the truth teller is now
what happens in this situation that
they're truthful toggler well then on
the second question what are they going
to do they're going to lie they're gonna
lie on the second question
right on cue on question number two so
if you know for a fact that someone's
going to lie how can you phrase a
question so you can figure out who the
truth teller is well if they say no to
this first question and you know they're
gonna lie on the second one
your second question should just be who
is not the truth teller not the truth
teller so the only way to lie on this
question right the only way to lie on
this question this person has to lie now
is to tell you who the truth teller is
and so using these two questions we
essentially using the first question are
you the truth teller we can immediately
predict what the person is going to do
on the second question and then we can
phrase the second question depending on
that response to definitely know who the
truth teller is anyway I thought you
would enjoy that and I hopefully you see
why the the the liar game show brain
teaser was a bit of a
warm up for this one see you in the next
video